lanthanum is the first element in the
series called the rare earths they're
not terribly rare but nevertheless
they're called rare earths and they're
they have they're all have rather
similar names so there is quite an
amusing little rhyme mnemonic that
people learn to remember the names which
and the first two letters of each words
tell you this chemical symbol the
elements of this that goes language
centers praise Ned's promise of small
European garden thumbs dinosaurs Hubbell
erotically thrumming yellow lutes which
takes it from lanthanum all the way to
lutetium lanthanum is the largest of the
lanthanides it's a prototype for the
lanthanide series and because it's the
largest it is the most reactive
it's a strange matter and that you can
actually cut it with a knife so it's not
actually that hard I haven't worked much
with lengths in them but one of my
students or a Russian visitor did some
rather interesting experiments with
making a compound of lanthanum and
copper so-called lanthanum cuprate which
is quite an interesting catalyst
lanthanum has got quite a few
technological uses it's used in of all
things lighting in Hollywood studios
lanthanum air can also be used in a
hydrogen storage now obviously the
hydrogen economy is becoming a very
important issue with the energy crisis
and so on and so forth and it's in
certain circumstances it's very
effective as what we call a hydrogen
sponge so it can suck up all of the
hydrogen and hopefully you could use it
a fuel source but because it's quite
heavy it might not be actually that
useful at the end but it's good to know
they can do that